decision making in Wales I have been
very impressed to date by the quality of
the submissions made to me by many of
the core participants and the commitment
that they have shown and I hope they
will continue to show
with the help of core participants I
hope we can conduct a thorough
investigation of the issues that affect
the people most in Northern Ireland and
meet an ambitious timetable that I have
set
it is in that way that I can reach
conclusions about the preparedness for a
pandemic and response to it and make any
recommendations as we go along
I am determined that the public of the
United Kingdom and for the purposes of
today's Hearing in particular the public
of Northern Ireland should not have to
wait until the end of the inquiry and
the hearing of all the modules for the
answers to their legitimate questions
and concerns and I wish to publish
recommendations that may reduce
suffering any future pandemic as soon as
practically possible
I'd also wish to emphasize uh that I am
determined that modules such as this
focusing on the devolved Nations
administrations will not be in any way a
sideshow they are a vital part of the um
hearings as far as I am concerned and I
will ensure that throughout the inquiry
in these modules and indeed in other
modules where we'll be looking at
matters that affect the devolved
administrations and the devolved Nations
that we properly investigate all
relevant matters
I have as far as this afternoon's
hearing concerned received written
submissions from some of the core
participants to the module I'm very
grateful to them I've read them very
carefully I will bear them all very much
in mind and it also means that because
they've been helpful enough to provide
them in advance they can keep their old
submissions to those matters upon which
they wish to focus and therefore
highlight so having said that could I
now call please on this Darwin lead
canceled the inquiry for this module to
explain in detail the issues for me to
consider this afternoon Miss Dobbin
well my lady on behalf of the console
team I want once again to welcome those
colleagues from Northern Ireland and
those from England and Wales to who
appear on behalf of the core
participants in module 2C and who join
us for this online hearing of course
that welcome very much extends to the
core participants too we're really
grateful for their interest and their
participation I thought I'd start if I
may by introducing those who are
represented and may I begin please with
the Northern Ireland covid-19 bereaved
families for justice who are represented
by Miss Campbell Casey
disability action Northern Ireland
represented by Mr Friedman Casey
the trade unions Congress and the
Northern Ireland Committee of the Irish
Congress of trade unions represented by
Mr Jacobs and you'll hear submissions
from all three
also appearing before you are the
commissioner for older people for
Northern Ireland represented by Miss
anyadaki Dames Casey
the National Police Chiefs Council
represented by Mr Phillips Casey
baroness Arlene Foster and Mr Gibbon
represented by Miss Ellison Michelle
O'Neill represented by Mr Bassett
the Northern Ireland Department of
Finance represented by Mr Hannah Casey
and the executive office of Northern
Ireland represented by Mr Sharp the
Northern Ireland Department of Health
also appear before you as well
there are many advantages to a remote
hearing but I'm sorry not to see my
learned friends in person it's worth
repeating that the module 2C hearings
will of course take place in Northern
Ireland and will have plenty of time
together then but I wanted to press the
point with my learned friends that
regardless of where they are situated
the console team for module 2C are
always available to speak and to be of
assistance to them
my lady with your leave on behalf of the
module 2 team I wanted to provide a
brief update to core participants on our
work and to address shortly some
discreet issues that I thought I might
be able to assist on before you hear
from core participants
I'm conscious that a number of these
points have already been made in the
other modules and so I will try to be as
brief as I possibly can be
so first of all equality issues
we last came together at the module to
see hearing on the 2nd of November 2022
and on that occasion it was clear that
there was a good deal of common grind
between the concerns of the core
participants and issues which were of
import to them and to those of the
inquiry
that hearing was important because it
always makes a difference to hear issues
being articulated
many of the submissions that were made
the points that were emphasized have
either been directly incorporated into
our work for example in the form of
questions that have been asked of
witnesses
or have been bookmarked as relevant to a
later part of the inquiries work
it's really important that I repeat at
the outset that through you my lady and
under your direction the council team
for module 2C regards it as fundamental
to its task that it understands how the
pandemic impacted on those in Northern
Ireland who stood to be
disproportionately affected or in
ordinary language who stood to lose more
whether that be by the virus itself or
the measures that were taken to
counteract it
that is the lens through which we have
approached our work to date and we'll
continue to do so
plainly much of the work in module 2C is
focused on understanding fundamental
issues much of a constitutional nature
to what extent was the core decision
making set by decisions that had already
been made by central government
to what extent did the northern Irish
executive have the latitude to do things
differently
or were politicians constrained by the
limits of their lawmaking powers
or pragmatic issues like access to
Scientific advice or central government
funding
overarchingly did the power sharing
model of government work for the people
of Northern Ireland in this time of
crisis
did a power sharing model have benefits
as compared to the usual model of
governance whereby scrutiny is provided
by political opposition
or were there shortcomings what
challenges did power sharing pose for
the politicians themselves
now these are all core issues but as of
you but as you have made clear my lady
of equal importance is the question of
how those how the interests of those who
stood to suffer a disadvantage by the
pandemic were taken into account in
making those key decisions in Northern
Ireland
now it goes without saying that those
who might or did in fact experience
particular disadvantage throughout the
pandemic May differ across different
parts of the United Kingdom
I wanted to make absolutely clear that
we are sensitive to that in relation to
Northern Ireland those issues have to be
looked at through the lands of
inequality or disadvantaged at
disadvantage in Northern Ireland and on
that we are at item with the written
submissions of the Duc and the Northern
Ireland committee
so the issue of inequality is firmly
embedded in the work of module 2C
given that I'm not sure that it's
necessary for us to frame the approach
that we are taking in module 2C in any
more formal terms
the principal work of a public inquiry
is to gather evidence to be objective
and fair to hold the line when it comes
to competing interests and rights in the
inquiry and ultimately to enable its
chair to come to conclusions or to make
recommendations which are founded upon
evidence which judged overall is
sufficiently detailed and reliable
but as part and parcel of that it can
examine the extent to which
consideration was given to equality
duties or the broader questions about
the welfare of different groups in
society
and an inquiry can achieve all of those
things and keep at its core The Human
Experience of those most affected by
events
ultimately of course the key decisions
made were made by people doubtless
operating under great pressure and in
Northern Ireland alone power sharing
having just been resumed after three
years and that's an important issue in
module 2C as well
but we are entitled to examine on behalf
of the people of Northern Ireland the
decision making and importantly the
Machinery which is intended to support
it but fairly and in particular in
Northern Ireland having a mind to the
political sensitivities at stake but not
being daunted by those political
sensitivities either
we set it up the first hearing but this
is a public inquiry for all and it's
vitally important that every part of the
community feels as though they have a
stake in it
and when it comes to it Witnesses must
Endeavor to go beyond the politics of
the personal and to ensure that the
focus of this inquiry is on our shared
Humanity
in analyzing the proceedings of the
Northern Ireland assembly committees
it's conspicuous that important figures
noted at the time that there would in
due course be a public inquiry that
would afford the opportunity to analyze
the decisions made or the basis upon
which they were made
some figures pointed at the time to The
Limited capacity during the pandemic the
analyze decisions made or to consolidate
their understanding
in addition to that the bereaved
families make a singularly important
point
because there are no power sharing
Arrangements at the moment they are
deprived of the scrutiny that they would
otherwise be in Northern Ireland through
the normal operation for example of
assembly committees after the event
in short my lady the moment for
self-examination and objective scrutiny
has come
and I repeat on your behalf how
important it is that those who are asked
to provide evidence do so without gloss
without defensiveness and having firmly
in mind the importance of using the
experience gained to informed what to
inform what could be done better in the
future and we're grateful to those
Witnesses who've been explicit about
this
as we refer to at the last hearing our
early work has thus been to understand
the mechanisms by which there was
assessment of the impact that decisions
would make or would have sorry on
particular groups in Northern Ireland
the equality act 2010 does not extend to
Northern Ireland protection against
discrimination is found in different
bits of legislation
the analogue to the public sector
equality duty is found in section 75 of
the Northern Ireland Act 1998.
but despite the different architecture
the concepts which apply principally of
the need to have due regard to promote
equality in respect of persons with
certain characteristics are familiar
across the Nations
in the context of a public inquiry of
course the issue might run wider than
that
in addition to Legal duties what a coin
was taken are how broader con
consideration was given to welfare or
the well-being of certain groups or
consideration about existing
inequalities and how they formed part of
the key decision-making process may also
fall to be examined and again to that
end an early part of our work was to
seek evidence from the statutory
Commissioners and were grateful for the
engagement of the commissioner for older
people who is one of our core
participants in this regard about their
role during the pandemic in relation to
the government decision-making process
we've also sought evidence from the
Northern Ireland commissioner for
children and younger people the equality
commission Northern Ireland and the the
Northern Ireland Human Rights Commission
to
the equality commission with the
Northern Ireland Human Rights Commission
has as is pointed out by disability
action Northern Ireland being designated
under the United Nations convention on
the rights of disabled persons as the
independent mechanism tasked with
promoting protecting and monitoring the
implementation of that convention in
Northern Ireland
and I wondered if I may to say a word
about disability action Northern Ireland
since the last hearing they've become a
core participant that's a welcome
development to us the point that almost
one in five people in Northern Ireland
have a disability alone speaks to how
important their participation in module
2C is and we look forward to working
with them
on behalf of the inquiry I wish to make
clear that we're sensitive to disabled
people not being a homogeneous group
I also understand that many disabled
adults or older people don't want to be
described in terms of being vulnerable
we do use that term in module 2C but I
hope that it's clear that it's intended
in the well understood sense of that
word in this context to denote the
clinically vulnerable are those like
children who need special care
but the main point is surely this the
representation of disabled people and
their families is a means of ensuring
that the inquiry can understand the full
range of their experience during the
pandemic and in their own words
we're grateful to disability action
Northern Ireland for setting out to the
inquiry the formal structures which
exist so as to ensure that account is
given to the rights and needs of
disabled people
as we understand the point they make the
importance of these mechanisms is that
they exist so as to produce better
outcomes for disabled people they're not
mechanistic it goes without saying that
part of the work of module 2C will be to
investigate the extent to which the
interests of disabled people were taken
into account in the key decision making
the disability Northern Ireland
submissions reiterate that these are not
novel Concepts they're part of domestic
law and reflect a consensus in
international law too
we're aware that the department of
communities has the lead responsibility
for Disability Policy in Northern
Ireland we have been provided by with a
draft statement from that department
which we are in the process of reviewing
but as an immediate step we will
consider any further questions that need
to be asked of that department in light
of the some in light of some of the
issues that have been raised in the
disability action submissions
after the hearing in module 2 you issued
an important ruling that first of all
the inquiry should obtain expert
evidence from a suitably qualified
expert or experts on the nature and
degree of pre-pandemic structural racism
the purpose of such evidence is to
assist you to understand the issue and
to provide a clearer evidential
Foundation upon which the specific
issues in module 2 can be explored and
developed
you directed that such expert be
commissioned and ruled that you would
keep under review the extent to which
such evidence would be needed in other
modules
second
as to whether expert evidence should
also be obtained regarding pre-existing
pre-existing structural discrimination
on other grounds and also on
intersectional grinds
you ruled that in the at the first
instance at least the inquiry team
should in addition to the expert
evidence in relation to structural
racism explore the possibility of
obtaining a single report covering these
other issues if necessary drafted by a
small team of experts who cover
different specialisms and my lady XR
respectful submission that you adopt the
same approach here and consider whether
the issue of pre-existing structural
risks and or other forms of structural
discrimination in relation to Northern
Ireland can be encompassed in that same
report
I'll come back to other experts if I may
in their written submissions the
bereaved families have raised the
question of whether the inquiry will
consider the impact of austerity
measures in relation to the pandemic and
by austerity we mean that to understand
the cutbacks to funding of Public
Services after 2010 and prior to the
outbreak of the pandemic merely did the
issue of budgetary cutbacks and the
impact upon Readiness to respond to the
pandemic it's part of module one
as you are aware one of module two sees
provisional terms of scope is the impact
of the absence of ministers and the
executive in Northern Ireland from early
2017 until the 11th of January 2020.
this is a distinct issue from that
raised in module one which is resilience
and preparedness
rather the focusing module 2C is how the
lack of a functioning executive in the
three years prior to January 2020
impacted upon the decision making of
those who came into power and who were
almost immediately plunged into coping
with the pandemic and the decisions they
made so the focus is not so much the
three years preceding the pandemic but
rather the reality which confronted
ministers when they took office and the
impact that had on their decision making
by way of example we understand there to
have been seven major reviews of Health
and Social care between 2001 and 2016 in
Northern Ireland the Bangor report in
2016 was regarded as important in terms
of it advocating a program for reform of
Health Care
disability action Northern Ireland have
also pointed to the new decade new
approach agreement of January 2020 which
was of course immediately impacted also
by the onset of the pandemic
you know may well be that the fact that
the Bengal report recommendations were
not implemented was a factor in decision
making in response to the pandemic and
again I repeat it's not an issue about
readiness rather it's about the
situation as it confronted ministers
when they took up the reins of power in
2020.
so my lady I think the short point is
that it's not within the scope of module
2C to examine the effect of budgetary
cuts or to focus on events before
ministers came into office but rather to
pick up the Baton in January 2020 and to
consider how that lack of an executive
up and until then impacted upon the
government response to the pandemic
turning them typing timetable
um
before going on to set out shortly some
of the work that has been done thus far
I was going to deal with the timetable
as it stands as our core participants
know the fact that module one will start
slightly later than originally planned
has a knock-on effect so that module 2
will start on the 29th of April 2024 and
I know that that signs distance but
distant but as we all know that will
come around soon enough
it does mean that we have a little bit
more time than the other nations in
module 2 to prepare for our hearings but
it also means that some of the core
participants in module 2 are under
pressure to provide evidence that may
form part of the hearings in both
modules one and two and module 2C we
knew for example that the Northern
Ireland Department of Health is dealing
with a large number of rule 9 requests
and that so too has evidence been sought
from the former Health Minister Mr Robin
Swann the former first Minister and the
former deputy first Minister two so
they've already been asked to provide
evidence to other parts of the inquiry
now the bereaved families have asked
whether we intend to ask Mr Swann for a
statement and may I assure them that we
do and plainly he will be an important
Witness
however it is important that we try in
as much as we can at the moment not to
overload
um organizations or individuals and
circumstances where we can afford at the
present to stagger our approach
the other point that we sought to make
in our note that we filed prior to the
hearing is that our timing affords a
little bit more latitude to take into
account evidence or information that's
being received before we ask
organizations to finalize the drafts of
their initial witness statements or
before we send real Minds to certain
Witnesses
we think for our part at least that it's
an advantage to Northern Ireland that
the module 2 hearing precedes us and
that some of the foundations will have
been laid before we take up the reins in
Northern Ireland
the approach Remains the one we
described at the outset it's an
iterative one our initial rule mine
requests are broad but we will
unvoitedly be issuing further nine
requests as our understanding develops
these May well be aimed at individuals
where where more detailed evidence is
needed on particular issues or where the
evidence polls were a more specific
response
so just turning very briefly to
timetable we're working to that hearing
which will commence in April 2024 there
will be a further preliminary hearing
the issue has been raised as to whether
three weeks is enough for a hearing the
inquiries of the view that having
thought about the ground to be covered
and considering that module one and two
will have preceded us and will lay some
of that grind work and that it is enough
time but in circumstances where we don't
yet have a witness list and haven't
sketched out our timetable it will be
premature to say that three weeks is not
enough
so turning then to rule 9 requests and
evidence
the module two scene leak 2C legal team
has now issued 83 formal requests for
evidence pursuant to rule nine of the
rules some of these are joined with
other inquiry modules particularly
module two and as we anticipated the
first round of them were sent to the
executive office the Northern Ireland
government departments the Northern
Ireland office executive agencies and
the chief medical officer
we've disclosed a first tranche of
documents to core participants
comprising material received from the
executive office and this includes
things like briefing papers situational
reports and the minutes from executive
meetings and we expect to provide
further materials to core participants
from other providers in the coming weeks
the inquiry has received approximately 3
000 documents in module 2C alone from
Material providers and it's anticipated
that there will be a significant a
significant volume of these will be
disclosed to the core participants
as we've explained module 2C is in the
process of developing its detailed rule
9 requests to the first ministers and to
the deputy first Minister and will then
move on to the minister for health to
other ministers and then to other key
figures and I repeat the point that
we've made on our note that we really
welcome and encourage the identification
of other potential Witnesses and that
we'll consider any other suggestions but
forward
my lady I say all of this because we've
noted the concern expressed on behalf of
the bereaved families that a number of
the rule 9 requests to date seek to
elicit what are described as corporate
type witness statements in plain
language these are the sorts of
statements of or requests for statements
often sent to government bodies that
require them to explain how the
Machinery Works how it did work during
the pandemic to identify who Key
Personnel are how they discharge their
functions during the pandemic and those
sorts of things in terms of core
political decision making
I think it's right to say and to make it
clear that this is important evidence it
isn't mere window dressing because as
I've said it's not just about
understanding how organizations work or
who the key individuals are it goes to
the point that under our system of
government those making the critical
decisions are elected politicians
they're not specialists in a given field
recruited to meet the needs of
government at a given time as for
example as sometimes the case in the
United States of America so it's really
important to understand and to
scrutinize how the Machinery of
government supports the key decision
making
that said we understand entirely the
point made that there's a risk that
corporate evidence in particular is
susceptible to glossing over problematic
issues or presenting the picture that
everyone within an organization is of
one mind or of one View
but I wanted to say this first of all
we're alive to that responses to rule
nine are not an invitation for the
provision of blondishment
rule 9 requests are not a carte blanche
for organizations to Simply say what
went well
organizations are being asked questions
intended to elicit whether for example
there were competing views on Central
issues and how the decision-making
process that supported government
accommodated a range of opinion
second regardless of what we ask and how
statements are provided we seek the
underlying material so as to be able to
scrutinize what the reality was at the
time
third those who provide foundational
witness statements May well be asked to
provide oral evidence
so a witness who has sought through a
witness statement to provide evidence
which does not reflect reality or which
glosses over the difficulties or offers
little more than that our organization
worked well type sentiments will be
examined about that and could be asked
questions if it's the case why their
statement did not reflect reality or did
not make clear that there were
difficulties
fourth there's already material which
has been generated by organizations
which have embarked on Lessons Learned
exercises or by other forms of
commission against which decision making
can be tested
fifth the inquiry will also be calling
expert evidence as well and again that
they that may
constitute another route by which the
decision-making processes can be tested
as well
of course module 2C is also open to
hearing from any individuals within
organizations or departments who
consider that they have important
evidence to give or who are concerned
that the full picture is not being
presented
the bereaved families have set out in
their written submissions and have asked
whether we intend to approach other
named individuals and organizations
which they have specified and I won't
hear my lady go into the detail of who
they are but I can say that all of the
individuals to whom they are preferred
are individuals whom we have planned to
send real minds and the position of the
rqi a is slightly different it's
responsible for inspecting and Health
and Social care services in Northern
Ireland and it's likely that that body
will have relevant evidence to give
across a number of different parts of
the inquiry but we will certainly
consider the issues it might be able to
assist with in relation to the key
political decision making
and separate to that Miss Martina
Ferguson who jointly leads the bereaved
families has also provided a suggested
list of witnesses as well and that too
has been considered and taken into
account by us
the TUC in the Northern Ireland
committee have also submitted that a
rule 9 request should be sent to the
health and safety executive for Northern
Ireland as the lead body responsible for
the promotion of health and safety at
work in Northern Ireland
following on from the last hearing and
pursuant to the submissions which they
made and bearing in mind the importance
of the agri-food business in Northern
Ireland module 2C did send a rule 9
request to the Department of Agriculture
environment and Rural Affairs but these
were questions related to the
vulnerability of persons who comprise
that Workforce granular issues about the
enforcement of the covet legislation and
guidance in the workplace are not within
the scope of module 2C
a further discrete issue my lady which
has been raised by the bereaved families
is that of the restrictions around
funerals and other gatherings in the
event of a death
I wanted to say again on behalf of the
module 2C legal team that we understand
that the people who lost family members
and friends not having the support of
others not having familiar rituals and
traditions which give Solace and not
being able to play pay tribute to a
loved one before people who knew them
all of those things must have been
extremely painful to bear and made
people feel very alone and absent
kinship
we're also conscious in module 2C
that particular significance is attached
to the role of religious ceremonies and
death and that these endure in Northern
Ireland and that there are cultural
considerations which are specific to
Northern Ireland in terms of how death
is marked too
consequently It's Our intention to
consider the restrictions related to
funerals in Northern Ireland as part of
the examination of non-pharmaceutical
interventions so in other words that
module 2C will examine whether or to
what extent a coin was taken of how
these restrictions would impact
deleteriously upon bereaved people and
the inquiry will return later to
examining in more detail the nature of
that impact
my lady the next issue the Republic of
Ireland
one of the terms of scope in module 2C
is the extent to which political
decisions were informed by the response
of the government of the Republic of
Ireland to the pandemic
also in your directions of January 2023
again having heard from core
participants you directed the inquiry
team to explore the relationship between
the devolved governments and the UK
government and between the government
and Northern Ireland and the Republic of
Ireland and the island of Ireland as a
single epidemiological unit
plainly the decisions made by the
Republic of Ireland are not within the
scope of this inquiry rather the issue
is how the response of the government in
Northern Ireland to the pandemic was
informed by the position taken by the
Republic of Ireland when it came to key
decision making
moreover pursuant to your direction our
rule 9 requests have asked recipients
about cooperation with the Republic of
Ireland more broadly we've sought to
understand the extent of cooperation
whether existing mechanisms for
cooperation were used if they weren't
why not whether there were barriers and
will continue to pursue that as a line
of Investigation of course subject to
your direction
the bereaved families of us specifically
whether we intend to send rule 9
requests to individuals or organizations
in the Republic of Ireland in order to
have evidence about what the response of
the Republic of Ireland to the pandemic
was
the short answer to this is no but I
wanted to set out the reasons why we say
that
first
much of the information about the
response of the Republic of Ireland to
the pandemic is already in the public
Arena
by way of example only the memorandum of
understanding which was made by the
Republic of Ireland and the northern
Irish Departments of health and their
respective agencies and this was
entitled covid-19 response Public Health
cooperation on an all- island basis
that's a public document and it provided
that the covid-19 pandemic does not
respect borders therefore there is a
compelling case for strong cooperation
including information sharing and where
appropriate a common approach to action
in both jurisdictions so in other words
it set out an aspiration and it's this
sort of publicly available material
which provides us with a yardstick
against which the substantive
cooperation which actually occurred can
be considered
second the disclosure that we have from
the Northern Ireland departments and the
Northern Ireland office to documents the
respective positions taken on issues
between the Republic of Ireland and
Northern Ireland or the United Kingdom
so in other words we have a good
understanding of those relationships
from the material provided from the
Northern Ireland perspective
third aside from Witnesses like the
minister for Health Mr Swann who will
obviously be asked questions about
cooperation and the mechanisms for
cooperation
other types of witnesses and I have a
mind Witnesses like the chief medical
office will also be asked about
cooperation not from a political
perspective but rather from a clinical
perspective too and again will be asked
questions about the use of mechanisms
whether the use of those mechanisms were
sufficient any barriers which existed
and so forth so in other words there are
different ways of testing and examining
this sorts of evidence and these issues
through the different Witnesses who we
intend to call
foreign
still on the subject of rule nines the
bereaved families have also repeated the
request that they be provided with the
rule 9 requests sent to witnesses as
you're aware my lady each month the
inquiry does send out an update to core
particip two core participants about the
rule 9 requests which have been made and
provides quite a lot of detail about
what has been asked certainly in module
2C as core participants are provided
with um statements and further Evidence
which will take place in due course
there may well be issues that they
consider ought to be included in further
nine requests or further evidence that
they consider we ought to ask for and
again I emphasize that of course it's
open to them to contact us about that
and that we would welcome that sort of
Engagement as well
next issue is that of a list of issues
like our counterparts and modules 2 A
and B we intend to provide a provisional
detailed list of issues to core
participants which will provide greater
clarity as to the matters which will be
examined in module 2C and my lady we
invite you to make a direction as to the
debt by which that ought to be served
and respectfully suggests that this
could be by the 31st of May 2023 so
following on from each of the dates that
have been set in the other modules
turning them to relativity malaria as
you know that's the platform which the
inquiry uses to disclose evidence to
core participants documents are
disclosed once they're assessed as
relevant to module 2C they're stored so
that they're searchable by providers or
key terms or by words they can be
converted into text documents and
internally searched too now I know that
in module 2C some core participants
expressed a degree of concern or some
frustration about the functionality of
that system and I just wanted to pick it
up here because the bereaved families
have repeated those concerns in their
written submissions but again and I knew
that this was set out in module two as
well equip is providing training
sessions and there's a link to access
videos of that training as well and I
know that the inquiry is also exploring
options to provide core participants
with addition functionality in terms of
coding and that there'll be an update
about this shortly
and a more substantive issue perhaps is
that of expert evidence
module two but in conjunction with
modules 2 A B and C has instructed a
number of experts
of these Professor ilsa Henderson from
the University of Edinburgh has been
instructed to report on the political
structures for Devolution within the
United Kingdom and the mechanisms for
intergovernmental decision making
between the UK government and the
devolved administrations during the
covid-19 pandemic and in other words to
explain the different bases upon which
each of the devolved government's rules
in relation to central government and
the relevance of that to the covert
pandemic so her report does provide
expert evidence from a political science
perspective as to the basis upon which
Northern Ireland is governed
Professor Thomas Hill from the blavatnik
school of government from the University
of Oxford has also been instructed to
report on international data related to
the covid-19 pandemic including
analyzing the effectiveness of the
decision-making of the UK government and
each devolved Administration in response
to the pandemic in comparison to other
countries and we anticipate that there
will be points of comparison relevant
here so for example with the Republic of
Ireland
Alex Thomas from The Institute for
government has been instructed to report
on decision-making structures of the UK
government in an emergency so in
particular looking at the cabinet office
and cabinet committees and so forth
separate to that Gavin Free guard and
who's the former program director and
head of data and transparency at The
Institute of government has been
instructed to report on the access to
and use of data by the UK government and
the devolved administrations during the
pandemic
my lady we've already flagged attractive
though it is to have experts who are in
a position to comment up across the
United Kingdom and obviously the
strength of that is that it provides
obvious points of comparison we
nonetheless recognize that module 2C May
well require some expertise which is
Northern Ireland specific
from my part we'll be in a better
position to judge that when we've
received all of the draft reports and to
and responses to further questions that
we've asked particularly of Professor
ilsa Henderson
in terms of evidence about Devolution it
also appears to us that we might need to
stand back and consider what more we
need or what expert evidence might look
like above and beyond the background to
devolution
so for example if the question is could
the government in Northern Ireland have
done more done more and more quickly
then obviously there may be questions of
law about what pars the government had
and there may be questions and issues
around the Practical limitations to
which I've already alluded
um so I think it's just a question of
delineation there's likely to be
evidence of fact on those issues it's
really just in terms of flagging that my
learned friends may wish to consider and
have a think about what more expert
evidence might lend to that sort of
evidence
as has already been indicated after
disclosure of those draft expert reports
those that have been commissioned core
participants will be invited to raise
points of clarification or new matters
that are agreed by the inquiry to be
relevant with each expert and I think
that will also afford the core
participants an opportunity to indicate
issues which might require dedicated
Northern Ireland expertise
and I'm going to turn briefly then if I
may to the hearings in module 2C they
are some time off so I'm not going to
spend much time today on this issue I
know that no one will thank me for that
it was really just to flag a few main
points and my lady rule 10 of the
inquiry rules mixed provision as to how
witnesses will be questioned in an
inquiry and here that will be an issue
of consequence given the enormous amount
of grind and to be covered and that
there must be a balance given the
pressures on this inquiry to produce
reports and recommendations which are
timely so that means that the hearings
will necessarily have to be conducted
with focus and efficiency and obviously
a very good deal of work will be done in
advance we don't expect that witnesses
will be called just to repeat what's
already in their statements they will be
focusing on the issue issues of
significance and where you my lady may
need to resolve points of dispute also
present to rule 10 only cancel to the
inquiry may ask questions of the witness
and requires no permission from you to
do so but under rule 10-4 the recognized
legal representative report participant
can apply for permission to ask
questions as well but asides that
put into one side those rules core
participants in module 2C will have an
important part to play in informing the
questions asked of witnesses
and in terms of how we intend to ensure
that each witness who is called to give
evidence at the hearing will be provided
with a hard copy bundle of documents for
their use of the hearing this will
include things like their statement and
any documents to which they may be
referred
an Evidence proposal will be prepared
for every such witness and this will be
circulated to core participants in
advance
and that will also include a list of
topics that each witness will be
examined about references to the
relevant parts of the witness statements
and Exhibits and a draft index of the
documents that will form the witness
bundle including those documents about
which the witness may be asked questions
so core participants will be asked to
review the evidence proposals and to
provide comments and to make any
submissions as to additional issues
which they may want to have raised with
a particular witness or any new document
that they consider should be included
and I can say that that would be
considered carefully and that a final
proposal will be circulated before the
witness gives evidence
in addition to that my lady the inquiry
will also adopt the additional process
or by core participants can meet with or
write to whichever they prefer the
module 2C 2C team following the
submission of their observation
observations and that's so that they can
explain the rationale underpinning their
observations so there will be a more
informal process of dialogue about what
oral evidence will cover and will allow
core participants to ensure that we've
understood the points that they seek to
make
and in terms of the opening and closing
statements and the module 2C team will
prepare a detailed opening and that may
for example draw on the evidence from
the module 2 hearings so this
effectively to set the scene from
opening module 2C and to introduce the
themes and the evidence which will be
explored during the hearings and some of
the key materials to which we'll refer
as well it's not likely that there'll be
a closing statement
the core participants who wish to make
opening and closing statements will be
welcome to do so and I don't think we
need to get into the detail of this now
but doubtless will come back to issues
about time limits and that kind of thing
on a later date
um
malaria wanted to finish then if I may
on the listening exercise and which has
been named within the inquiry as every
story matters
and it's part of the work of this
inquiry that it will gather and
assimilate the accounts of people across
the United Kingdom about the impact of
the pandemic on their lives
and as has already been observed such is
the breadth of Human Experience of the
pandemic that this is really the only
way I'm ensure that record is made of
the accounts of those who wish to
participate
there will be a new online Forum with a
save and come back feature so that means
that people can record their account at
their own pace but have the ability to
come back to it if they want to and the
inquiry has also received input that
there needs to be other ways for
participants to provide their accounts
so that will include things like a phone
line and a paper form too
there will also be in-person sessions
with a specific focus on hearing from
people who might not otherwise come
forward or who would welcome Bane with
other people who suffered bereavement or
who had similar experiences to them
the inquiry wants to hold Community
listening events across the United
Kingdom too which will be attended by
inquiry staff and I know my lady that's
subject to your inquiry commitments that
you would like to be able to attend some
of those as well and there will also be
an ability to participate in different
languages
and the inquiries approach to developing
every story matters is premised on an
understanding of the trauma that people
have been through it's informed by this
and where possible emotional support
will be available
the accounts given will be analyzed and
reports will be produced for each
relevant module investigation and they
will then be submitted as evidence
disclosed to the core participants and
also published as part of the evidence
in those hearings so in this way the
experience of those affected by the
pandemic will be integrated into the
inquiries core work
the inquiry is also about to launch a
number of tenders to procure specialist
services to support every story matters
to these are separate contracts which
will follow on from the existing interim
ones which come to an end shortly and
these new contracts will cover research
to gather analyze and report on people's
experiences
Communications to create content that
raises awareness of every story matters
so that people can take part if they
wish and community events expert
provision to help the inquiry gather
experiences face to face from people
within the community
and I said this at the last hearing but
obviously we very much hope that people
from across Northern Ireland will
participate and we encourage them to do
so it's really important that their
voices are heard as part of this inquiry
and my lady you've been clear from the
very outset that you wanted to find a
fitting means within this inquiry of
commemorating those who died
to that end the inquiry consulted as
widely as possible as to what might be
appropriate again given the scale of the
loss and to that end my lady you decided
that a tapestry should be created and it
would be a physical installation each
panel created by a different artist
working with a particular Community or
communities to develop it
tapestries have been used as a means
throughout history of capturing the
common experience of significant events
or of remembering them
perhaps uniquely a tapestry is a form of
art which is able to both involve and
reflect different communities which is
traditional but nonetheless is also one
which can be modern and that seems so
important given the diversity of
experience and loss which it will
capture and of course more than anything
it's a piece of art which will also
endure
the intention is for the first panels to
be shown at the UK inquiries Hearing
Center in time for the first substantive
hearings in module one in June the
panels will be transportable to wherever
the inquiry holds hearings in the UK so
people in Northern Ireland will be able
to see them if they attend in person
it's also planned that films which
convey
which convey and explain about harm and
suffering caused by the pandemic will
also be shown at the commencement of
each hearing too and this will include
module 2C sub slant of hearings also and
I think further details about that are
set out in the solicit of the inquiries
note from January
and my lady those are the opening
submissions on behalf of the console
team I think that all I otherwise need
to do is ask your permission that the
core participant submissions be
published on the inquiry website and on
behalf of the inquiry team I wanted to
thank core participants for the care
with which they have considered the
issues and the constructive way in which
they have sought to engage with us and
with the inquiry too I can't say or
Express clearly enough how helpful that
is and is there anything that I can
assist you with at this point thank you
very much indeed Miss dobbyn no there's
nothing else at this stage and I'm
grateful to you may I just before I call
on Miss Campbell King's Council
apologize to those who may have had
problems with the streaming on our on
the inquiry website
um I gather there was a problem but I'm
told that it has now been resolved but
for those who are members of the public
or the others who are trying to follow
via the website don't worry I'm I'm
reassured or assured that the core
participants attendance or participation
in this hearing hasn't been affected
so perhaps you can confirm that Miss
Campbell if you're there
my lady I am and I I can thank you
um my lady on behalf of the Northern
Ireland Brewery families may I once
again welcome the inquiry if only
virtually in this hearing to Northern
Ireland
this inquiry and this module in
particular is of the utmost importance
to all of the bereave families here in
in the North
the families as you know have long
campaigned for an inquiry
and a Northern Ireland inquiry it's fair
to say in particular
but as has been recognized by Miss
Dobbin this afternoon the ongoing
political stalemate if I can call it
that in the north means that a northern
Irish Pacific inquiry is no closer to
reality nor is in fact the ongoing
scrutiny that might have been expected
in the aftermath of the pandemic and so
in reality your inquiry represents the
only opportunity for bereaved families
in the North
to get and to gain and to bring some
understanding of their individual and
collective experience during the
covid-19 pandemic here in Northern
Ireland and accordingly it is very much
welcomed and it is very much appreciated
by the northern Irish families
it is hoped that your inquiry and in
particular through the focus on Northern
Ireland in this module will provide much
needed scrutiny of decisions and
indecision
of action and inaction of communication
and miscommunications are in some cases
a wholesale lack of communication and
importantly of opportunities and missed
opportunities
that Afflicted those who we lost and
those who and I bereaved
these are all issues that continue as my
lady knows well to cause heartbreak to
the bridge across our society
and my lady expectations really of this
module in this inquiry are therefore
very high
module 2C in particular from a northern
Irish perspective has an enormous task
and a very important function and I can
say on behalf of the Northern Ireland
covert bereave families for justice that
we are very much here to assist the
inquiry in achieving a team
my lady knows that a very significant
amount of work has already been
undertaken by the berry families and
indeed by their representatives in order
to assist you in identifying our shared
and Collective experiences through key
themes and through recurring issues that
have been shared across the brief
families and therefore in identifying
lessons that really require to be
learned as a result of their experience
and as a result of their bereavement
um it's regrettable but it's perhaps
unsurprising that there are many shared
experiences and therefore we feel many
lessons to be learned
you will know of several of them my lady
having already read the detailed
statement that was provided on behalf of
the bereaved families submitted by
wherever rule 9 responds to module one
and I can assure my lady there is indeed
more to come
but if I may um given that the focus is
on Northern Ireland today if I may I
will draw your attention to some of the
issues noise so that our families can be
aware that they are if I can put it
colloquially on your radar or on your
list and that if not today then in the
near future the inquiry can give us a
necessary Assurance as to how and when
they will be addressed
may be in due course we're told that
some of the issues are not to be
addressed in module 2C but will be
addressed in module one or perhaps more
appropriately in module three which is
Healthcare and module four which is
social care
however given our previously aired
concerns that there must be sufficient
and meaningful focus on Northern Ireland
within the wider modules and of course
your Assurance to the families that that
will happen if I may or will address
them shortly today
I I had entitled them discrete issues
but that might inadvertently diminish
their importance
can I start with and there are four and
the first is the issue of north south
cooperation
this is perhaps increasing in prominence
in our submission
because of its relative and it's I
should stress the word relative absence
in the scope of this module and indeed
in the um Council to the inquiries
written submissions well of course we
have listened carefully to the oral
submissions this afternoon
and it is right that we should observe
that the provisional scope of module 2C
does include the extent to which
decisions made during the pandemic were
informed by the response of the
government of our of the Republic of
Ireland
um that references undoubtedly an
acknowledgment of the unique political
and indeed Geographic geographical
situation that Northern Ireland is in on
any view our unique position called for
a different approach to governance
during the pandemic than in any of the
other Administrations
however we respectfully contend that
that reference in the provisional scope
does not go quite far enough
my lady long before the onset of the
pandemic and this is no doubt going to
be recognized in the disclosure that we
receive
but long before the pandemic hit it was
recognized politically and by Health
institutions that the island of Ireland
is geographically a single epidemic
epidemiological unit with a cross-border
public body The Institute of Public
Health being responsible for Public
Health on the Ireland of our and the
island of Ireland
and that of course is surely born at the
very least from Common Sense there is
free movement of people across the
island people live in one jurisdiction
and work in the other families live on
either side of the Border people shop
socialize or access services in one
jurisdiction or the other jurisdiction
or both jurisdictions
neither Westminster nor the Northern
Ireland executive nor the Republic of
Ireland government controls all ports or
points of entry into this jurisdiction
and there's as a result there are many
cross-border and intergovernmental
bodies and political institutions most
set up in fact under the Good Friday
agreement to recognize and facilitate
our unique situation
so for example the north south
ministerial Council the north south
interparliamentary Association the
British Irish Council and the British
Irish into parliamentary body
and while this scope of this module
recognizes that there was a need to be
informed by decisions of the Irish
government we contend that this inquiry
will have to do much more to consider
and to assess both the UK's Central
government's interaction and cooperation
with the government of Ireland
and those cross-bordering
intergovernmental bodies
as well as the interaction between the
storm and executive and their
counterparts in the Republic of Ireland
these are important political structures
for us here and their existence and
their actions may have had a bearing on
a response to the pandemic but they
don't appear in the operational scope
they didn't appear in the CTI note for
this hearing nor in fact do many of
those bodies appear in the annex
relating to rule 9 requests for evidence
and submissions
and it's our permission that they really
do require to be examined and of course
uh we hear and we understand the point
made by Miss Dobbins that really on on
an examination of the disclosure from
one entity one can get a very strong
impression perhaps even a a inaccurate
and a full impression of the impact of
another but that might not always be the
case
and so it's of such importance that we
would in fact invite the provisional
scope of module 2C to be amended to
reflect that cross-border communication
and governance will be considered so
that to the extent isn't that it that it
is possible and indeed necessary lessons
need to be identified and learned and we
are of course ready and willing to
assist in in that process and to
communicate with your team in order to
identify the appropriate cross-border
institutions and governance that ought
to be approached
um it may also be that a means and an
effective means in order to fully
elucidate the importance of these
cross-border institutions is to identify
an appropriate expert in the both the
political institutions and framework of
Northern Ireland vis-a-vis Westminster
and vis-a-vis Dublin and also within
that to address the unique Health and
Social care framework and that might
well we suggest be a relatively
streamlined way in which to properly
reflect the unique situation in which we
operate in in the North
malaria I'll touch briefly on the issue
of austerity as Point number two a
Maloney friend has again addressed this
this afternoon and we're grateful to her
for her submissions and once of course
this is not an inquiry into the
pre-existing state of health services or
public services be it Healthcare or
social worker and nor could it be we
contend that so far as Northern Ireland
is concerned the inquiry must
acknowledge again either by way of
expert evidence or otherwise the really
perilous state of Public Services in
Northern Ireland before the onset about
or of the pandemic
many of our families are in no doubt
that their loved ones were ultimately
victims of their Health and Social care
system in a state of near collapse and
the fact that it has been in the state
of near collapse is widely recognized
both in in literature and also uh in
expert evidence given to other court
cases in in Northern Ireland
and so it's it's our submission that the
impact of that austerity that we have
addressed in our written submissions
combined with the long periods of the
absence of a functioning executive left
the prevailing Health Care system and
social care system in a dire State
before before the pandemic and decisions
made and this is important in terms of
bringing it within of course the scope
that those pre-existing pressures
um were real and that decisions made in
the context of those have got to be
examined
and therefore in order to properly
consider the impact of the pandemic on
Health and Social care in Northern
Ireland we must first understand the
prior state of the Health Care system
my lady Point number three is
communication and we've addressed it
briefly at paragraph 16 of our written
submissions in that paragraph we set out
concerns about communication during the
pandemic and give the example of
Communications in relation to Care Home
guidance
my lady you will know of course that
equivalent concerns exists on behalf of
those who were hospitalized and in
particular around the nature and extent
of medication that was dispensed and
around the decisions made in relation to
resuscitation
and so too do those concerns exist on
behalf of the very many people in
Northern Ireland who were cared for
within their own home environment by
what we colloquially known at what we
colloquially know know as Home Health
the experiences of our families is that
the messages from Stormont trickling
through each of the Health and Social
care trusts were mixed confused and
inconsistently applied and why that may
be an issue more appropriate for module
3 or module 4. we invite your team to
liaise with us to identify when and how
those the evidence touching on this
aspect of communication will be
addressed and so that the experiences
and the concerns of the bereaved will be
heard and the questions that our
families have as to when this will be
addressed um will be answered
number four was that of Social and
cultural and religious customs
and I can say at the outset that Mr
Dobbins indication today that within the
scope of module 2C consideration on the
Restriction of works and funerals will
be very welcome used to the bereaved
families
you will my lady on your tour of the UK
and kind of a great many cultural
differences on behalf of different
groups and different regions and that's
of course uh one of the joys of this
nation but in Northern Ireland the
social culture and religious importance
of holding weights and community
community funerals really cannot be
overstated
Community grieving is integral to our
society
and as a result of that the restrictions
on Gatherings and mornings collectively
as well as the hands-off or a rather
hazardous way that deceased loved ones
were treated on their deaths caused
immense pain and distress at the time
and continues to cause heartache to
those who lost loved ones and it's just
one of the ways in which the pandemic
impacted differently in this
jurisdiction but a very important one
and so thank you to you my lady and to
miss Dobbins for indicating that that
will be given consideration in module 2C
as I as I I say that reassurance would
be very welcome news to the families
turning if I made to the agenda we
recognize the start date
um had to be put back slightly and so we
will start this module some 13 months
hence and we acknowledge knowledge both
the reason and the need for some delay
however we do really question whether
the proposed 14 days or three weeks
minus a bank holiday is sufficient
in our respectful submission it is not
um
if I must say so premature to allocate a
greater degree of time at this stage uh
given the unique issues that have to be
addressed uh it is appropriate and we
will submit ought to be recognized that
14 days is very likely to be inadequate
in order to address all the issues that
need to be addressed and that greater
time needs to be allocated in order to
allow for that proper scrutiny and one
just has to think of not only the unique
geographical situation the political
dysfunction and instability before once
I might say during and since
uh the input from Westminster and Dublin
the unique Health and Social care
framework all of those called for a
greater amount of time to be allocated
allocated in fact
at a conservative estimate we would
respectfully submit that a timetable uh
in fact twice as long would easily be
filled with important evidence to be
scrutinized
uh touching my lady on the room nine
Sorry Miss Camel I'm sorry to interrupt
you I as you know I like to give the
stenographer a break because um he or
she has a lot to put up with
um I don't mean that in any pejorative
sense as far as your submissions are
concerned
um any idea I don't want to rush you I'm
happy to take the break now if that's
convenient or if you'd rather
complete your submissions but it depends
on how long they're going to be I I
would have thought perhaps another 10
minutes in which case if you don't mind
we'll take the break now yes of course
uh very well 15 minutes please so that
means I should be back at 20 past three
is that right was it quarter past
sorry I'm just checking my watch
foreign
sorry about interrupting you and about
the confusion over timing I've got to
sort out my watch
dog
um my lady I was moving on to the topic
of rule nines and Rule nine requests and
may I start with an acknowledgment from
the outset and it's an important one
there is a huge task being undertaken by
your team to seek and to obtain all
necessary disclosure and information
from all uh necessary and relevant
individuals
and so we don't underestimate for a
moment the enormity of the task and nor
do we underestimate the diligence that
is being applied to it by your team uh
true to her word Mr Dobbins has reached
out to us uh to explain the work that is
ongoing and the timetable that surrounds
it and we're grateful for that
indication and also the reassurance
however Milady we are in a position to
assist with that process
and it's our respectful submission that
we ought to be given a greater
opportunity in that regard
it will have been apparent both from our
written submissions to this module but
also from submissions made in other
modules that if given an opportunity if
given sight for example of a list of
recipients of rule 9 requests we are in
a position to identify absentees we are
in a position to identify other relevant
individuals and agencies who ought to
have been approached and it's fair to
acknowledge that once we have done so
there has been action on behalf of
behalf of of your teams across the
various modules and just by way of
example we raised in our written
submissions and approach to the rqia and
we're grateful through Miss Dobbins this
afternoon for an update on that but
there is also the institute for public
health in Ireland we have identified
Northern Irish ministers for health UK
Minister as the Secretary of States and
Republic of Ireland equivalence just
being some of those
we also have identified and these are
submissions echoed in fact on behalf of
disability action and of course the TUC
the various Regional Health and Social
care trusts and the directors and
management in those trusts
my lady will be aware that Miss Ferguson
whom we represent has provided very
lengthy and detailed uh list of names
and individuals who may be approached
we're also in a position not only to
identify absentees but to identify
sources and additional sources of
material that must be gathered
and whilst we of course acknowledge that
it is an iterative process being
undertaken by your team at an iterative
iterative process in which we only have
that limited if you like Outsider
participation is not as reassuring as as
might have been intended
but my lady the families and individual
members of our group
have an enormous repository of
experience and of information and of
knowledge and we urge the inquiry to
adopt it therefore a greater degree of
openness in relation to the Gathering of
information under rule nine requests and
to permit us a greater degree of
participation in this process
and that can be achieved by sharing the
detail of the real nine requests which
is a submission that we have made
previously
by sharing the full list of recipients
and by receiving submissions from us not
just in relation to a list of names or
organizations or agencies but in
relation to the substance of what must
be asked and from whom
we have in addition in our written
submissions raise the additional concern
of what might be termed a top heavy
approach to
approaching individuals ministers and
agencies so therefore seeking their
kinds of senior ministers or
um a a line adopted from
um the kinds of the inquiry submissions
a corporate statement and of course that
is necessary we don't suggest for a
moment that it is in any way window
dressing but we are Keen to ensure that
if there are dissenting voices those
voices are heard and given an
opportunity to be heard
my lady will be in no doubt that there
is value in the accounts and opinions of
others further down the chain below the
top Edge loans
and how does this inquiry ensure that
there was a concert obtained as a
question that we ask
at paragraph 38 of our written
submissions you will have seen that we
propose various means by which the
inquiry might ensure that dissenting
voices are heard including a
well-publicized invitation to
individuals within relevant entities to
come forward if they feel able to to
provide information if they feel able to
or by casting the net wider in relation
to rule 9 requests and we are due and
your team to consider those suggestions
with care and in the round
it is of the utmost importance to the
brave families as I'm sure of course it
is to you my lady that the gold picture
is presented and represented in the
evidence
and we can't rely on either
um the accounts given only by those or
the top or the willingness of
whistleblowers to come forward
um of course we acknowledge that a
greater degree of insight will be
available to us when wider disclosure
becomes available but we wears it as an
important issue that shouldn't be
overlooked at this stage
and my lady turning to disclosure
um really under this heading we rely to
a very significant extent on our written
submissions again we understand the
volume of work that is being undertaken
but but we do repeat previously voice
concerns about the balance that must be
struck between redacting personal or
sensitive information and timely
disclosure
many of us will have had experience of a
redaction being applied on the basis of
uh something that appeared
inconsequential only for it to have
become important in the fullness of time
and our concern would be that a blanket
redaction for example of names on an
email chain even if of Junior officials
might belie patterns of communication
that on proper scrutiny become important
and that's not just because of the
presence of names included on a list
but also because of notable absences of
names in terms of communication
um that ought to have taken place
and so therefore we again urge the
inquiry against the use of blanket
redactions notwithstanding its
attractiveness in order to facilitate
disclosure and for expediency purposes
and we're willing to work with your team
to find the best way through that
we've raised in our written submissions
the platform for disclosure and I can
simply say that increased familiarity is
not generating generating increased
fondness for the platform or for its
functionality
um we uh welcome the indication today
that work is ongoing to provide us with
coding or with tags as we call them to
enable or to increase its functionality
that in fact hasn't been our experience
so far and and certainly I was under the
impression that we had reached the end
of the road in those discussions but in
fact if we're wrong about that and if it
is going to be possible to assist us
with Search terms
um that then we welcome that as as news
today
my lady the issue of expert Witnesses
um I have touched on previously
it is worthy I think of note that of the
two expert reports disclose so far in in
module one
does not even mention Northern Ireland
in terms at all
and the other that report more recently
disclosed on on healthy inequalities but
on an initial read doesn't assist at all
with the framework of our political or
Healthcare System and in fact and I
don't wish to to criticize it is only on
an initial read but Affairs to address
Northern Ireland only in relatively
light terms
and therefore we maintain our position
that this inquiry would be assisted by
an expert
um to give evidence firstly on devolved
government on Northern Ireland on the
complexities of the political Health and
Social care system and their
relationships between Belfast
Westminster and Dublin
um my lady we of course can understand
why the approach might be to to wait and
see um we have a number of experts still
to report
but but in our submission uh it would be
appropriate to seek to identify those
experts potential experts at this stage
and we are willing to work with your
team in order to assist in that process
because in our submission an expert or
perhaps two experts if if required would
be of particular importance to this
inquiry in identifying Lessons Learned
for future pandemics in this
jurisdiction and on this island
and in fact to a significant degree
would likely streamline the evidence
that is to be heard
um
what hearing
um schedule we have nothing to add and
we welcome the news that there will be a
further preliminary hearing
the issue of parliamentary privilege
well we have made earlier submissions on
that in earlier modules and it seems to
us that it is a bridge to be crossed as
and when we come to it
um I'll address briefly the issue of
rule 10.
um and as have you have heard
undoubtedly in in previous preliminary
hearings the opportunity for a council
on behalf of core participants to
question key Witnesses on Central issues
would not be to detract from Focus but
hopefully to assist in in focus on
issues that are of significant
importance to the core participants
um we will of course work very closely
with your teams
um in working through witness bundles
when they are provided and identifying
issues in identifying questions both
formally in written submissions and
informally in
um in discussions and with no doubt that
the Assurance is given today that the
core participants voices will be heard
as part of that process are given in
very good faith but we invite you
malayadi to leave open the opportunity
at this stage the possibility and in
fact the probability that there should
be questions on behalf of the bereaved
families of key and important witnesses
to them we acknowledge that the
timetable is tight but once again the
fact that one has set a and what we
would respectfully submit is a Too Short
a timetable is ought not to be used as a
reason
um to indicate that there is inspection
time for Council on behalf of core
participants to ask questions on behalf
of those they represent and but that is
a a matter that we will continue
um to work with your teams in relation
to
I'm a lady finally the listening
exercise
um Northern Ireland cover brief families
for justice and their legal
representatives are ready and willing to
assist in this process to the greatest
extent that we can
it is understood as an exercise to be an
enhancement of the opportunity for
individual participation in the inquiry
rather than alternative to it of course
and I can assure my lady and I know um
you you having met some of the bereaved
families that we have much to say in
this jurisdiction and individuals are
ready and willing and Keen to share
their own experiences and the
experiences of those they have lost no
matter how difficult it is for them to
do so and so um as and when the
opportunity arises it will be taken up
by many of those whom we represent
and I make clear that we are of course
ready to welcome you back as part of
that process it was observed by Miss
Dobbin that you in fact have
participated and will continue to do so
the fact that many of our members have
had the opportunity to share their
experiences with who has already been
the source of deep gratitude and is
often discussed by them as something
that is important and so should the
opportunity arise
um then as I say we would welcome it
again
um but meanwhile now we will continue to
work with your team in order to
facilitate that level of communication
with the listening exercise
thank you thank you very much Miss
Campbell particularly thank you for the
um very positive uh approach in relation
to listening exercise I've said before
and I think you've heard me say it that
my visit to Belfast I found one of the
most moving occasions and I shall
certainly return
um not only just for this module but on
other occasions if I possibly can so
thank you very much indeed thank you
Mr Friedman
good afternoon my lady I hope you can
see me I can thank you very much Mr
Friedman
uh we act I think as you know for
disability action Northern Ireland and
they are also making their first
appearance in the module we are grateful
to miss Dobbins King's Council and her
team for the way they've updated on
matters this afternoon and in particular
the way she has engaged with our clients
provisional highlighting of their issues
we emphasize to you this morning
disabled people's triple jeopardy during
covet they're far more fatal covert
outcomes they're cut off from other
acute health care and treatment issues
and the disproportionate impact of
lockdowns and related measures upon them
the triple jeopardy profoundly affected
the one in five people of Northern
Ireland and according to the latest
census moving to one in four who are
disabled that includes that during 2020
they were 48 more likely to die of covid
and 40 more likely to die of non-coveted
causes than non-disabled peers
in addition there are those unique
features of Northern Ireland including
the suspension of devolved power from
January 2017 to January 2020 and the
resumption of dissolved power in the
first crisis period of the pandemic
response in 2020 only to collapse again
in February 2022 of course all pretty
much within the timeline of your inquiry
the effects on disabled people of having
no executive for long periods has been
the issues that can take years to gain
traction with the functioning government
without anyone to properly engage with
as disability action has written policy
decisions relating to disabled people's
lives were left in the hands of local
civil servants who in the absence of
ministerial authorization often felt
powerless to act
meanwhile politicians in Westminster
grappling with brexit in a myriad of
other bigger issues seemed entirely
removed from addressing the challenges
disabled people and their families in
Northern Ireland were facing
during the pandemic disabled people
situation continue to be Complicated by
such bigger issues including the
political differences within the power
sharing Arrangements a direct
consequence of the collapse of the
executive in 2022 is that an ongoing
commitment to produce a disability
strategy as part of the program for
government that was agreed to in January
2020 has not been realized that is
despite a commissioned expert panel
report advising the department of
communities on how to do so being
completed now some two and a half years
ago
and all the circumstances Geraldine
mccahim is the chief commissioner of the
equality commission for Northern Ireland
warned in October 21 that political
disagreements and a fixation on what she
called the orange and green issues has
resulted in a two decade-long failure to
enhance legal protections for minority
groups and she consequently describes
equality protection in Northern Ireland
as comparatively in the Dark Ages
for the purpose of module 2C the inquiry
will need to consider whether the
post-conflict preoccupation of
maintaining the political equality
between the power sharing parties
especially in the context of brexit
adversely affected the protection of
minority groups during the course of
covert decision making including for the
reasons introduced today disabled people
in urging my lady to incorporate human
rights analysis into your investigative
toolkit it is right to identify what
makes the Northern Ireland approach
distinct we mentioned formatters
relevant to disabled people but also
other minorities
First Northern Ireland has a discrete
architecture and culture of human rights
that is tied to us to its existence and
well-being as a post-conflict society
it runs through the special focus on
human rights in Northern Ireland
contained in the Good Friday agreement
1998 which affirms commitment to quote
the right to equal opportunity in all
social and economic activity regardless
of cross Creed disability gender or
ethnicity and commits the creation of
statutory duties and oversight
mechanisms
those mechanisms are realized in part
seven of the Northern Ireland at 1998.
they are expressly protected by the
so-called no diminution of Rights
principle contained in Article 2 of the
2019 Northern Ireland protocol that has
not been changed by the recent Windsor
framework
the Northern Ireland office outcome
delivery plan for 2021 2022 consequently
includes an outcome six of its quality
objectives to quote ensure compliance
with UK public sector equality Duty and
section 75 requirements of the Northern
Ireland Act contribute to reserved human
rights work including treaty body
requirements sponsor the new Northern
Ireland Human Rights Commission and
ensure implementation of the node
diminution of Rights principle in the
Northern Ireland protocol
second
notwithstanding this commitment to Human
Rights work including treaty body
requirements the Northern Ireland
government unlike Scotland and Wales has
no clear plan to implement the UN
convention on the rights of persons with
disabilities
it is one of the casualties of the
absence of devolved governments that the
plan to get a plan has stored
of particular significance to modules 2C
will be the criticism by the UN
committee on the rights of persons with
disabilities in 2017 of the
ill-preparedness to protect disabled
people in the event of an emergency
which combined with austerity measures
that had the effect of stripping
disabled people of assets required to be
resilient in the face of emergency have
had their consequence
while none of the four nations fare well
on this Northern Ireland lacked evolve
government when engagement with the UN
committee's criticisms could have led to
meaningful planning as transferred
matters under the Northern Ireland Act
which is not the case with Wales and
Scotland are a discrete issue as such
with few exceptions the equality act
2010 as you've heard does not form part
of the law of Northern Ireland rather
the disability discriminated
Discrimination Act of 1995 remains in
force
hopefully Northern Ireland therefore
does not have the equivalent of section
one of the equality act 2010 to bring
into Force even if it wanted to
public authorities in Northern Ireland
have to comply with Section 75 of the
Northern Ireland act which requires them
to have due regard to the need to
promote equality of opportunity between
various groups including those with and
without disabilities there is an ongoing
debate in Northern Ireland seemingly
blocked by repeated suspension of
devolved government as to whether those
Provisions should be replaced by a
structure more akin to the equality act
2010 as applies to the rest of the UK
there is also some suggestion no doubt
to be examined with Witnesses the
intersectional thinking is relatively
underdeveloped in Northern Ireland
overall My Lady if the stalling of the
political process has stored engagement
with structural discrimination against
disabled people generally
then as disability action discovered in
his survey of 404 people including 1300
written submissions the situation after
March 2020 served to quote reveal the
fragility of Independence for disabled
people and raise questions about the
strength of disability rights in the
face of such a crisis
as the organization put it in September
2020 in their report on the impact of
kodu 19 on the people of Northern
Ireland
what became very clear they say was the
feeling of many disabled people that
their voices were being lost in the
noise or were simply ignored in the
confusion and panic that was unfolding
we've addressed in the module two and
the earlier sub module hearings various
matters about how expertise and experts
might be viewed from the point of view
of disabled people's organizations
for Northern Ireland May we add the
following
first the disability action found
minimal consultation with disabled
people's organizations in Northern
Ireland in covert decision making and
its conclusions are confirmed by the
independent panel of experts that
describes consultation as too often
tokenistic
second
in so much as disabled people's
organizations can and should assist the
inquiry as experts then disability
action are such an organization
the reports they were commissioned to
write or have otherwise cited made them
well placed to explain what they have
described as the tension in the approach
of protecting vulnerable people during
the covid-19 crisis whilst at the same
time removing services for vulnerable
people which had a detrimental impact
upon their physical and mental health
third and by way of observation on the
presently instructed experts we support
what other CPS have said in this hearing
and the hearing for Wales this morning
as to whether the forthcoming reports
will need to be supplemented by devolved
power experts for those discrete Nations
and we've heard Miss dobbyn explain she
wants to reflect on that and invites our
reflection along with her
the Northern Ireland there are undoubted
idiosyncrasies relevant to comprehending
its policy formation including as you
just heard its cross-border dimensions
they include the administrative and
Health Care Connections with the
Republican of Ireland and how the big
issue post-conflict politics effectively
crowds out other social issues
other variable local nuances concern
data collection and its gaps and
disaster preparation and resilience for
a pandemic especially for disabled
people in a jurisdiction that has been
particularly braced for other types of
emergency and disaster for its troubled
years and peaceful ones but was not
prepared for an emergency of this nature
and fourthly on structural
discrimination in my ladies ruling on a
group of experts can I mention the word
vulnerable
I've been stopping rightly noticed it
will have it will have to be used from
time to time when referring to things
like shielding and the clinically
vulnerable
but we appreciate that she is also aware
of the complexities of the term
like the rest of the UK covered decision
making and its framework relied heavily
on a division between the labeled
vulnerable for there for uh to be
distinguished for various reasons from
everyone else
that policy framework casting the
non-verberable are sacrificing for the
vulnerable did not work to save disabled
people from covid's triple jeopardy it
is also served to avoid sufficient
report about underlying social
inequalities deflecting attention away
from the administrative arrangements and
systems that distribute disadvantage
across people and groups
we therefore submit that in its
instruction of experts and questioning
of witnesses the inquiry will want to
understand how disabled people as a
category and with and in parallel with
others were rendered vulnerable when
denied the resources and assets to
absorb the covert emergency with
resilience in the manner that I
mentioned this morning
my lady finally on the procedural issues
that can turn all that concern all of
your modules two and two a to 2C we do
not repeat what we have said in writing
and orally previously
thank you for allowing us in these
public preliminary hearings to introduce
perspectives and sources that our client
has reason to know will assist you and
your team to prepare the next stages of
this inquiry with disabled people's
situation in mind
it is also important for disabled
members of the public to hear these
matters introduced into a public forum
which they are often not and for
allowing that our thanks are also due my
lady those are us missions Mr Friedman
and thank you very much and the um those
you whom you represent
um as I said this morning you raise some
extremely important and serious points
and
the ones will be bearing very much in
mind and we should welcome the
assistance that your lay clients can
provide so thank you again thank you
Mr Jacobs for the TUC and the Northern
Ireland do you see
okay
sorry Miss Jacob I think I've got the
name wrong the yeah
[Music]
it's just
right I represent the trades Union
Congress and the Northern Ireland
Committee of the Irish Congress of trade
unions
the Tec supports its 48 member unions
which brings together approximately five
and a half million working people
many of its member unions have members
across England and that of old Nations
and including in Northern Ireland
the Northern Ireland Committee of the
Irish Congress of trade unions
represents Affiliated membership in
Northern Ireland and for ease my lady I
will refer to it as the Northern Ireland
committee
it is the representative body for 34
trade unions with over 200 000 members
across Northern Ireland and in
membership terms it is the largest Civil
Society organization in Northern Ireland
uh may I make one preliminary
observation my lady which is that Mrs
Miss Dobbin spoke at the outset of her
submissions if I may say so in a
sensitive and also compelling way as to
how the inquiry should approach the
political sensitivities in Northern
Ireland and the focus of the inquiry and
perhaps this module in particular being
on our shared humanity and I would like
to say that that is something with which
we um agree
so the purposes of today I intend to
address just a few matters arising out
of our written submissions and of course
stand by the rest
the first matter is time tabling and and
I will Echo a submission
um made by Miss Campbell on behalf of
the cover brief just a few moments ago
um and a submission made by myself and
others this morning in module 2B
the inquiry has timetabled um 14 days
for all hearings in this module and with
time permitted for opening and closing
statements and assuming councils the
inquiry makes such statements also
that will allow 12 or perhaps 13 days of
oral evidence
it is presently the only hearing states
to be taking place in Northern Ireland
and focused exclusively on the pandemic
of Northern Ireland
of course we do not yet have um witness
statements yet alone a peer idea on
Witnesses but we can say that to us 14
days seems extraordinarily short and
although you will have heard me make
these points this morning my lady I do
feel it's important that I repeat them
in this module
um as as we see it there are two
difficulties the first is a problem of
appearance of it appearing that the
Northern Ireland here in is the poorer
relative of more robust consideration
given in relation to Western decision
making in module two now my lady I of
course listen carefully to the uh some
of your opening remarks this afternoon
and your assurances that the devolved
Nation modules if I can call them that
will not be a sideshow they will be a
vital part of the hearings and evolve
Nations issues will also be considered
in other modules and let me make clear
we do not doubt those assurances for a
moment
but we still say that the bare fact of
such an apparently short hearing
um remains problematic significant
issues will necessarily be left off the
table at least in relation to oral
hearings and with the current time
estimate it appears to us that it would
be impossible for it to be otherwise
the second related problem my lady is
the problem of being able to
meaningfully test an array of complex
issues in such a short time frame
we recognize of course as an inquiry of
this scale must proceed in significant
part with reference to written evidence
but even so the current time estimate
appears to us to be problematic
that is all or more so given the points
which we consider to be compelling made
by the Northern Ireland cover blue
families for justice as to the
particular importance of this module to
Northern Ireland and also to its
complexities
at the very least we ask that whatever
practical Arrangements the inquiry is
making for the hearings of Northern
Ireland it retains scope for extending
the timetable but as I observed this
morning you may my lady wish to grasp
the Nestle now and extend the timetable
recognizing that it is perhaps
inevitable and when it comes to the next
Blue new hearing it would be helpful if
counsel to the inquiry and others know
um that further time is available
my lady I turned to rule nine requests
in our written submissions we made
observations in relation to four
organizations but for the purposes of my
oral submissions I'm going to focus on
the health and safety executive of
Northern Ireland
the TUC has invited a rule 9 request to
be directed in module two to the health
and safety executive and we understand
that that is now in train
which appears to us that that is
important because the HSC is a GB wide
regulator for Great Britain white
regulator for health and safety at work
and it has a role to play in providing
guidance to employers and also in the
monitoring and enforcement of workplace
safety including non-pharmaceutical
interventions
in module 2 C we say that a rule nine
requests should be made of the health
and safety executive for Northern
Ireland
it is an executive non-departmental body
sponsored by the department for the
economy
it is the lead body responsible for the
promotion of health and safety at work
standards in Northern Ireland
I understand from the observations made
by miss dobbyn this morning that no rule
9 request is to be sent to the health
and safety executive of Northern Ireland
and the reason for that is said to be
that granular issues around enforcement
of guidance in the workplace and not
within the scope of module 2C
my lady we firmly disagree
the health and safety executive of
Northern Ireland as I have said is the
lean body responsible for the promotion
of health and safety at work standards
in Northern Ireland and that it appears
to us gives rise to important questions
which do fall squarely within module 2C
what did it know about the effectiveness
of non-pharmaceutical interventions in
the workplace and the guidance being
published or not published by the
Northern Ireland government
what did it know about the impact in the
workplace of the virus but also of the
non-pharmaceutical interventions upon
protected and vulnerable groups
crucially were concerns about those
matters known to the health and safety
executive of Northern Ireland has
communicated to the Northern Ireland
government
equally crucially if they were
communicated what governmental response
was there
where the health and safety executive of
Northern Ireland's needed government
assistance in relation to its role in
monitoring and enforcing
non-pharmaceutical interventions did it
get it was there adequate governmental
cooperation
to us these all appear to be crucial
questions of significant important
importance to module 2C to the political
and administrative decision-making of
the government
we do not accept that the health and
safety executive of Northern Ireland or
evidence from that organization can be
described as simply being granular
issues around enforcement
workplace safety was crucial in the
pandemic and should have been crucial to
governments and governmental and
administrative decision making it was in
the workplace that many would have
caught the virus that resulted in a loss
of life it was also in the workplace
that many of the unequal and disparate
impacts were felt by Frontline workers
deciding not to hear from or even in
fact not to seek evidence from the lead
regulator for workplace safety in
Northern Ireland would in our view be a
matter of concern
quite separately
if granular issues around the workplace
enforcement of non-pharmaceutical
interventions are not going to be
considered in module 2 or 2A 2B and 2C
we ask that urgent consideration is
given as to where those issues will be
considered and that is something we have
urged before
numerous sectors saw difficulties in
workplace safety in Northern Ireland in
particular there were concerning
outbreaks of food processing sites as
early as March 2020 unite Northern
Ireland Regional officer Sean McKeever
described food and Retail workers are
now Frontline workers in the battle
against the covid-19 virus but are at
risk of being sacrificed by our
politicians the Northern Ireland
executive shameful failure to bring
forward any meaningful enforcement
mechanisms whatsoever cannot be allowed
to continue
the HSC is chronically under-resourced
and understaffed to deal with a scale of
this challenge they are no longer
conducting inspections of workplaces
leaving workers to fend for themselves
my lady I say that is striking Frontline
workers often low paid and in a
Workforce with a number of protected and
vulnerable groups disproportionately
over-represented working with their
lives at risk and without any
inspections of the places in which they
work
without change that will happen again
in the pandemic non-pharmaceutical
interventions in the workplaces were
crucial and in a future pandemic they
will be crucial again
but non-farmaceutical interventions in
principle without any effective means of
monitoring or enforcement is a
fundamentally flawed system and we say
it must be grappled with in this inquiry
it is a key area for lessons to be
learned
so to summarize my lady we say that
evidence from the health and safety
executive for Northern Ireland
absolutely is relevant to module 2C
certainly in relation to its
Communications with government
um quite separately we are concerned by
the idea that issues of workplace
enforcement do not fall within this or
other module 2 modules and ask
um where it does
my lady next and very briefly the issue
of strand tie hearings again I raised
this for the record having raised it
earlier but it certainly our view that
um it will be important to have some
opportunity to consider after modules
2a2b and 2C the lessons that are to be
learned across the four nations and
Council to the inquiry this morning in
module 2B spoke of it being in that
respect to Unique opportunity and that
is something with virtually absolutely
agree
just finally my lady um the listening
exercise we wish to put on records that
we strongly endorse the importance of
the listening exercise it will be
important that the listening exercise
captures the experiences of those at
work and both for TUC and the Northern
Iron committee stand ready to assist
my lady those are my all submissions for
the purposes of today I'm very grateful
Mr Jacobs you've made the concerns of
those organizations you represent very
clear and I shall obviously pursue them
all but in particular I understand
having heard you this afternoon the
concerns about the health and safety
executive at work so um I will explore
those matters with Council for the
inquiry thank you very much for all your
submissions okay Miss Dobbin do you have
any submissions by way of response
well my lady I mean no discourtesy to my
learned Friends by not responding in
detail to The Helpful submissions that
have been made clearly there are points
that require further consideration by
you there are perhaps just one or two
things that might help if I just pick up
on though and in particular Miss
Campbell's submissions about the terms
of scoop and the short reference that's
made therein to the Republic of Ireland
and I just wanted to make clear that
obviously the terms of scoop are set out
in quite that it's it's put in a Pity
way but I hope that the detailed list of
issues that we will um provide in due
course will set out more clearly what in
fact Falls within that term of scope and
might be helpful in that regard and I
also just wanted to pick up on one point
made by my learn from Miss Campbell as
well about the rule nines and I think
she suggested that it wasn't clear to
the bereaved families to whom those
rural nines were being sent and I just
wanted to make clear again that where
real nines are sent to individuals that
will be indicated in our monthly updates
because we have been focusing on sending
out the departmental ones that's why
they're not individual specific and I
just wanted to make the point again
because maybe I didn't explain this very
clearly but obviously there those
departmental rule 9 requests and the
responses that we get will inform the
more detailed rule Minds that we do send
out to the sorts of individuals
to work with the news departments in due
course and of course the families will
know and to whom those have been sent
and I just wanted to reiterate again as
regards the witnesses and Miss Ferguson
for example had suggested as might been
potentially relevant and we have taken
that on board and again some of those
individuals will be sent through all
mines as well so I just wanted to make
it clear that obviously there's room for
dialogue and communication on those
issues
and just in terms of then the experts
and this is the final Point
um on devolved issues and when I was
suggesting what's been described as a
wait and see approach what I really had
in mind was that my learned friends may
just want to consider the things that
the experts have been able to touch on
and then to think about the things that
we might we might need that sort of
dedicated Northern Ireland evidence on
and I'm told that experts on devolved
issues and are actively well there's a
process to identify them so the inquiry
is certainly getting on with that
regardless of the position that's taken
I didn't want my learned friends to
think that that was just something that
wasn't being Advanced that's very much
underactive consideration so I hope that
that's helpful and unless I can help you
any further with anything
no thank you very much Mr Stone
um everyone's been extremely helpful
again and um
like to express my gratitude for
many of the suggestions made and I I
will take them up with Council of
inquiry and I have absolutely no doubt
that um the core participants assistance
is in improving uh the work that we do
uh we're developing as we go along we
try to remain flexible and therefore the
submissions as I've heard today both
this morning and this afternoon will
help us in that development so thank you
everyone who participated thank you
everyone who watched online that
concludes today's hearings thank you